I'm gonna load up SCP but I've also got pretzels so I'm kinda ... eating pretzels..
714..
*Cronch Cronch*
*Cronch*
*Music Plays*
mm that's good
That's good
Mm!
Mhah!
*munch of satisfaction*
Mhh that's good!
Okay!
*sNifF*
One more..
*chew chew chew chew*
Alright, you ready?
*smack smack*
You ready?
Alright you ready??
YOU READY?
I dunno..
Man, gimme another one.
IT'S GWOOD PWETZELS...
DE'RE GWODDAMN GOOD PWETZELS...
Man, they are good. Mmm.. (Don't talk with full mouth markimoo)
Hooh!
Dat's a gwood pretzel...
MM Mn AAH Mm
*munch of satisfaction x2*
Aa, that's good.
Hang on, one more.
*Crunch crunch crunch*
Maybe one more
*crunch*
Da wos a small one
that was a small one I had before
mm OH
*large inhale*
Oh, A+
mehh forget the game, hang on
alright, well just go back to this.
*nom nom CRUNCH* aw yea
Now that's a slice of something pretzel.
NYA HAH
I got you? Yea, im funny m.n-
MAHAHA
Eh, one more.
I can do one more
*crunch crunch*
mm MHM
NUAH
WOAH
OH this is even better than the FIRST
*Nom nom*
OOOHHHHHHHHHHHHHHH
Eh, one more (sigh)
*CRUNCH*
*CHEWING SOUNDS* (Welcome to Markiplier's new food review channel btw)
You ever just-
you ever just eat a pretzel? (Yea we use dem as cigarettes still)
One more, one more. I cant just--
*crunch*
OOH
I gotta wash it down.
got too much pretzel in my gob
*MEGA SLURP*
*Markimoo contemplating the Pretzels he just ate*
(Meanwhile God: What the hell is he doing?!)
You ever feel like youre forgetting some'?!
EAGH one more
mm nam OOH
Now its stuck all in my teeth.
Hang on this in gonna take a bit.
*Mark getting food out of his teeth*
(god: seriously can you just-)
Its really stuck in there.
there we go.
'kay. one last wash
*EXTREME MEGA SLURP*
aah
*Again thinking about the Pretzels he just ate*
(god: DON'T U DARE)
Yeah, one more.
just gonna do one more.
im no- I'll-  i'll do two at once.
AaaAh  *markimoo is satisfied*
That's so dry.
aah its so dry
you guys ever had a pretzel?
and its DRY?
It's really dry.
It's like they made these pretzels without water.
Maybe it's like every odd number of pretzels
Is more MOIST, and the even numbers
are more dry.
Let me try three.
*CHOMP*
*Man fake screaming* *FREEDOM!*
(god: My "me" this is cringy ah)
It's even dryer.
It's more dry.
its t--
Its like a desert *blugh*
It's like it could be-- it could be just sand
Inside them.
It's still dry.
*Weak burp*
It's dry.
No, I don't think four-- I don't think four would be any--- any--
Any wetter.
I think four would be worse.
UGH
I think four might--
YA THINK??
ARE YOU A SCIENTIST?!?!
Try five?
Well I- I only got this many left
that's prolly, I don't think that's five.
I mean, I'll do four, But I- I just wanna say for the record,
I don't think
You guys are telling me to do four.
I don't think that I-
I don't think thtat this is gonna help the situation.
At all.
I think that this is only gonna exasterbate it.
Which means to make it worse (uh huh)
*shrugs*
*CRUNCH*
(A pretzel was lost into the abyss)
I- UGH fu- I dropped it.
AAH
hang on
*crunch*
(god: *sigh*)
ITS WORSE
YOU TRICKED ME (sorry mark :))
you tricked me!
Ive been had. It's so dry.
Four is like the dryest.
Off all the combinations I had, two was dry
three was really dry
But four takes the cake
the really dry, not moist cake
that was borderline unpleasant.
now they're all over the place in my mouth.
*starts picking at teeth*
It's really in there, hang on.
Have you guys ever watched Great British Bake-off?
Now I know why they don't make pretzels on that show.
'nother sip *YET ANOTHER MEGA SLURP*
ackKKKK
Imma go back to one, just to see if like it's any different now.
well, that's fine.
thats fine!
ones fine, one's good!
I like one
One.-- One- ill have one more- ill have one more
mm
mmmm
*deep inhale* MM
*lip smack*